[Music]
yesterday the Los Angeles City Council
voted to shut down all of LA's medical
marijuana dispensaries so I guess no one
in Los Angeles will ever smoke pot again
I guess that's the that's it well the
laws the law good while it lasted
yep let's have it everybody
[Laughter]
pass it forward
you believe that she's gonna have
absolutely no impact that's all done
whist you understand very good right
I'll just walk away now what else is
going on strange facts coming out about
both presidential candidates a new study
suggests that President Obama's emails
are more personal than Mitt Romney's
emails
yeah Romney's usually end with best
regards mitt while the president's
usually end with I killed Osama bin
Laden that's actually on his stationery
now happy birthday Kip a United Nations
Commission has called for the worldwide
legalization of prostitution yeah this
idea is getting a lot of support from
the global humanitarian group pimps
Without Borders it's been revealed that
North Korea's leader Kim jong-un
recently got married he got married yeah
so congratulations to Kim jong-un and
his new wife Katie Holmes
[Applause]
I feel good about this one
hi hope it's not one of those rebound
relations
that's love any modern family fans here
that's a pleasure the the cast of Modern
Family has delayed production for the
new season due to a contract dispute
driving contract disputes so they've
yeah they're not working yeah meanwhile
Andy and I are still asking TBS for a
urinal cake in the men's room what's
going on with that by the way I I
thought it was just a cake
we don't want a cake in the men's room
come on think about it
you talked me into it yeah take on a
rope that's nice a Health Group you're
gonna like this I'm not asking you I'm
telling you a a Health Group is
concerned about a growing trend of women
getting surgery to create designer
vaginas women women are getting surgery
to create designer vaginas yeah however
for women on a budget there's also the
popular Old Navy vagina
[Music]
anyways yeah those the ones with cargo
exactly
handy very handy looks like one of those
days what am I gonna put my cellphone